お前らも責任があるんやぞもっと正気に
なって新犯人を探せよ悪はソフトの中に
しか存在しないハードは全て全であるそれ
が今リベラルが言っとんのは殺される側の
理論やねリベラルがはびこったのは朝新聞
のせいやない
か安倍まで遮られちゃったやつなんです
けどハードとソフトの話もう1回改めて
伺いたいですみんな間違えとるのはね体罰
を悪だと言うからいかんの
体罰は全なんだだけどソフト体罰の仕方
それによって悪になりうる自動車事故が
起こりました自動車事故が起こったのは
自動車が悪いから違うよね運転の仕方が
悪かったからだ自動車がハード運転が
ソフト事故というのはあるいは悪はソフト
の中にしか存在しないハードは全て全で
あるそう思ってだから力を否定する人力が
悪だっていうやろ力が悪なんじゃない力の
使い方が悪なんだ力の使い方で悪なのは
暴力普通正しく使えば力は全なん
だ力は全て悪くというのがリベラルの言い
方じゃな力を使うから消しかららんあれは
弱者のいい分野ねからもう自分が力がない
もんで喧嘩しても負けるあるいはえ学力も
知力もないもんで昨日みたいに論争しても
負けると力は悪だって言いだすんやね自分
にとって悪なんだ力はね群れのためにある
んだ個人のためじゃないのだからその力を
自分のために使うよあるわね金儲けして
自分だけ儲けるとか会社で社長だけが給料
取っちまうとかこれ力を悪く使った場合や
ねだけどちゃんと使えばみんなのの給料が
高くなるそういうことになるねいですか力
はまず全である使い方を間違えると悪くと
いうそれがわからんやねそれが今リベラル
が言っとんのは殺される側の理論やねやれ
ば負けるという人間の言い分野ねだから
自分が負けるような力を持った人みんな悪
になしちゃうんやねあれは自分を守るため
に悪になっとるんやマスコミもそうやね
あれだけギャギャ言ってくのは自分たちを
守るためや
ね自分たちがリベラル教育を散々押し進め
ておいて右翼を否定してリベラルを肯定し
たわけやろリベラルがはびこったのは朝日
新聞のせいやないか日本の情けない文化系
はみんな朝新聞の奴隷やないか朝新聞の
言うことが正しいなんて言っとる大学の
入試に転生人後から出るとかね情けなと
思わんか
本の中で理性と本能についてハードウェア
とソフトウェアの言葉で説明されたと思う
んですけどそれももう1回伺ってもいい
ですかええ本能はハードウェア理性はその
本能をどう使うかソフトウェアだから今
投稿拒否とかま神経症なんかがそう何が
怖いかと言ってハードが狂っとるんだ学校
なんて怖くないはずやむしろ喜んでみんな
行くやろこれが怖いていうのは本のが狂っ
とるんやどうして狂うかというと弱すぎる
から弱いとすぐ狂うやろどんなもんでもだ
から本能を強くしないと本能を正常にし
ないと治らんわけじゃん東校拒否とかは
理性が狂ってるのではなくて本能が狂っ
てるです本のが来るとだってあの頃情緒
障害児って言ったじゃん情緒って何情緒
っって何よ情緒はエモーション
エモーションというのは本能の中の感情な
んや本能も地上位の3つに分かれるのその
うちの感情本能のこれがエモーションなの
そうすると理性言葉は本能に届かないわけ
やろカウンセリングで治るわけないじゃん
本能が狂っとるんだからどうしたら治る
本能強くすれば強くすれば狂わなくなる
からあいつは学校恐怖症って言っとったわ
ね恐怖症の1つよなぜか知らんが
アドレナリンが出てくるんやね
アドレナリンが怒りの作るというけど違う
んやアドレナリンは恐怖を作るんだ普通は
そんなもの判断地があるから抑えちゃうん
や今はそんな時期はないむしろドーパミン
を出す時はわあ学校だというその時に学校
人がいる怖いというそういう風になっ
ちまう対人恐怖症やね投拒否ってみんな
対人恐怖症じゃん人が怖くてしょうがない
強くしてらええじゃん人が怖かったら社会
性がゼロということになっちゃうもんねだ
からトレーニングして強くするのただし人
との接触がない人間はいつまでだっても
強くならんよお母さんというタイプのやつ
ねお母さんが出しゃばってくるんよね子供
の前に立ちはかるわ見とるとなそういう
ところは子供をダメにする社会性ゼロと
いうそういう子供が出来上がっちまうね
同校拒否の生徒は理性が狂ったとは考え
られないですか理性やねよくマスコミの
バカどはいじめがあったから投稿拒否体罰
があったから投稿拒否っていううんね
ハードのミスはソフトでは補えないそうや
ねソフトのミスはハードで補えるんだだ
から本能がしっかりしとればソフトいじめ
で嫌だな思っても学校行けるんや学校
ドパミンが出るからねそれをカウンセラー
15年かかってこうなったんだから15年
かけて直しましょうねなんて言いやがるん
と言われた方は15年待つんよそのまま
トレーニングもせずにますます遠いてくん
よねダメになっていくもうダメだから勝手
に仕上がりやって蹴飛ばせや嫌でも社会に
出てくやないか出てきや多少とも強くなる
んやから
ね本の中で戦争を起こすのは理性だって
いうパワーワードがあってそれが結構気に
なってるんですけどもう1回伺ってもいい
ですか侵略戦争やね侵略戦争はね起こしと
もロシアみたいにウーとこう首と目がけて
いくなんてことはないんよほんの自分の
縄張りのちょっと外までは侵略するんや
そうやってね縄張りを大きくしていくんよ
だんだんだんだんだけど中国でもロシアで
も全土バーと侵略していくじゃん力で持っ
てねだからあいつは悪ないだけどそれを
入れまいとする側防衛側これ悪じゃないよ
ね全に決まっとるじゃんだから戦争を悪く
というのは嘘ない
侵略したら悪防衛したら全だねそれを戦争
悪で一国にするもんでおかしない存になっ
て最後にあのコメント欄で結構視聴者の方
がコメントしてくださるんですけど以前
あの小ままに体罰以外の反論しろみたいな
おっしゃってたじゃないですかそれ
ちょっと視聴者の方にもちょっと同じこと
を体罰以外のことで反論してこいっていう
のをいだいてもいいですか罰反対でうちは
罰するから悪い50年前に言ったことや
ないだけどよう考えたこら自分たちのいい
という教育のおかげで何百万もの人間が
一生ダメにされとるんや人生を奪っちまっ
たんだそれについて謝れよイコぶりこして
マスコミなんかと一緒になってうちを攻め
とる連中お前らも責任があるんやぞお前ら
が正気やったらあの子たちは助かったんや
ねだから民主主義の定義できるか民主主義
というのは権力の体性ない権力は必ず腐る
これが前提となっとるで腐ったらさっさと
交代させれば革命を起こさんで済む革命
なんか起こしたら国が弱くなっちゃうだ
から民主主義にして革命を起こさずに腐っ
た権力を取り替えればええんだこれが民主
主義なんだ教育がダメになった登校拒否が
何10万とできた文部省が腐ったからやろ
なんで腐ったんやマスコミがリベラルで
やれリベラルでやれと言うから腐ったんや
ないかでうちに文句言ってくるやつはその
シマ乗っとるにお前らも責任があるもっと
正気になって新犯人を探せよ犯人の味方を
するんじゃないねみんながいい人になり
たいリベラルだといい人だと思えるだから
リベラルやっとるんじゃんちっともいい人
じゃないいい人は非常な努力の末に作ら
れるんだ自分で作る自分の属するところが
リベラルだからと言っていい人じゃないだ
から上から目線で人にものを言うな下から
目線で言えお前らの方が下だ以上DET
[音楽]